like many of his teammates also is
looking forward to the World Cup
I support Argentina because my favorite
player is Messi I don't have other
favorites I'm an Argentina supporter
always the 10 year old only started
training last year but already has Big
Dreams of becoming a football star in
his own right
I want to play for the national team so
I need to practice a lot and I have to
listen to my coach
his coach is this man al-atri known as
coach Aji by his students for nearly 40
years he has trained hundreds of
children offering free lessons for those
from low-income households
I am very proud my heart is happy I have
never regretted it or counted my losses
and games
he even purchases boots and jerseys for
Ozil and other students football is one
of Indonesia's most popular sports but
many families can't afford training the
efforts of cultures like Aji make the
game more accessible for children from
low-income households
some of his former students have made it
into the national leagues including
azrazifa Kyla who has traveled the world
playing for the women's team
coach Aji doesn't see how rich or poor a
person is but he has talent he will
support him until he makes it
she often visits her former coach to
help train some of the new students
coach arji says he's proud of all of
them but turning them into professional
players is not his main goal
I want these children to play football
so they can be strong and be confident
so they can have a good future nowadays
football schools are expensive but I
believe football should be cheap
football belongs to the people
he often dips into his savings to pay
for equipment and hiring the field a
cost he says is worth it when he sees
what his students can achieve Jessica
Washington Al Jazeera Jakarta